hello there rejects
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey we're
gonna watch the second trailer for Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood don't spoil the
end game is what Tarantino is saying
Tarantino demands your silence did you
see that it's becoming a trend now all
these directors trying to get people not
to spoil original content ridiculous I'm
gonna make a petition to ask them to
stop doing that make a petition to have
every movie spoiled before it comes up
yeah geez hey guys I want to thank
everyone who has been following us over
at our patreon page really really am
grateful I mean especially all through
Game of Thrones a lot of more followers
over there over there we do weekly q and
A's as well as TV show reactions stream
along this is me trying to my sincere
voice for it was like attack on Titan
latest season Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood one punch man my hero
academia dawn did all of haunting of
Hill House Cobra Kai season two I'm
gonna continue Gotham this week and
supernatural and several of those shows
have reaction highlights included those
are attack on Titan Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood one punch man and
supernatural I know yeah the stream
along forgave my thoughts are on there
and John does music video coverage
weekly go ahead on over to our you know
the sentence patreon that Bethel
swatches
[Music]
if you Dalton it's my pleasure then mr.
Schwartz your son
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
all right what's matter partner it's
official buddy I'm Kate I'm in the movie
you're in this meet I play Miss Carlson
[Music]
[Music]
I got comfortable
[Music]
because perry change
[Music]
you're a [ __ ] dummy don't you forget
it
which bunch of feelings oh yeah you're
having all that fun they're like oh you
haven't the Manson stuff we forgot about
that part
yeah there's little this Hollywood
nostalgia and yeah you know it's food
you've been fun to watch Rick Dalton
struggle with his career then you
realize like oh this is probably gonna
get this is gonna lose learnt with yeah
very serious darkness I'm liking the
approach a lot because it feels like a
biopic about Rick Dalton yeah it does
Nathan character but if it feels like
we're watcher watching the the end of
his career the life of it and that's
gonna really be focusing on the
primarily the relationship between him
and Brad Pitt the stunt double bérenger
I love that crack about like is this
your son like you know doing like what
maybe the tension between the two of
them and so it's dude you got Pacino and
Kurt Russell in the same movie with
DiCaprio and Brad Pitt they're gonna be
a whole bunch of other Tarantino
regulars in here and stuff like that
Margot Robbie looks great yeah she looks
like she's gonna give a hell of a
performance here rest in peace Luke
Perry man oh yeah well then he gets to
have a to being a Tarantino movie
because NASA doesn't get a lift through
this experience but man what a what a
way to keep going Timothy Olyphant
who's become like a favorite of mine I'm
really bummed that santa clarita diet
got cancelled listen to is the podcast
episode you did come over I was
hilarious things I've ever heard yeah
yeah yeah you're gonna be having other
actors show up in here I know Tim Roth
is supposed to appear James Marston he
looks like with Brad Pitt's character
that he's dating a girl who's a part of
the Manson Family
it seems like a lot of the the actual
Manson Family stuff will come in the
form of prep hits character being thrown
into this world you got Rick Dalton
who's the neighbor of when the murder
takes place and watching like the tonal
shift of the trailer I get this
impression that this is it was kind of
giving me the vibe of what Tarantino
himself as common Sidhant about the
changing time in Hollywood I would say
from 1969 a very specific type of film
era that we're looking at and then
you're watching a very pivotal point in
history happened with in Hollywood and
going into a much darker path and I mean
you're also paralleling that with you
know where Rick Dalton's at in general
you know with his career and stuff like
that you know the passing of an era
stuff like that yeah it's uh it looks
like it's gonna be pure Tarantino
faux-fur it's a mixture of a lot of fun
and then also some really dark stuff and
one thing the trailers don't give you
but Tarantino excels at and and I get
that vibe just from loving all his films
there's gonna be some real tense scenes
like all that stuff on the Manson family
farm it looks like it's gonna be a very
tense moment when I gotta imagine that
the kind of stuff that just because we
know the context will pick up a lot of
probably extra attention and extra
dimension because of that you know yeah
that you can play in a lot of really
subtle ways with what we already know is
an audience in this scenario anyway
because so many this is an infamous
story that he's at least borrowing from
for the backdrop yeah just I'm kind of
cute curious what uh like the overall
focus of it will be it's like the really
pitch that's in the whole rig Dalton's
storyline and then this Manson family
stuff will eventually happen in the
movie and they're exploring so much is
it just like checking in with him on
like a lot of different sets of Rick
Dalton going on to this movie or Brad
Pitt's character a cliff going on to
another set there's so many scenes and
locations it's like more than what I'm
used to with a Tarantino film oh yeah
one and I'm sure that at least some of
these scenes and locations will be on
backlots or whatever in part of movies
they're shooting and one thing I got
excited about that I just forgot to
anticipate about this movie and it makes
the most sense because it's about
Hollywood is I got imaginable probably
get to see Tarantino have a lot of fun
jumping through different film styles
with the different
that they're making yeah there's that
one shot in this trailer from the Nazi
film yeah you know and those moments
especially seem like they'll be good
moments for Tarantino to stretch his
legs and have fun you know and a more
appropriate like I like his historical
sort of fiction approach that he's been
taking with his more recent films
I feel like this kid like is you know
like inglourious basterds has its
interludes and stuff like that I feel
like this movie could really well
justify and probably have fun with some
of those film style interludes you know
yeah I also like that we're really
getting a see Sharon Tate as it as a
character I look on her own you know and
like this seems like we're gonna be
getting scenes Werth's just margot
robbie scene she's just by herself yeah
so this really feels like an ensemble
piece yeah so far yeah and it really
makes me curious as to how the movie is
going to play out because you know
they've said it's not about the Manson
murders but it's certainly a prominent
aspect of the time in places me this
trailer especially is showing you that
no no this is playing a very important
part in this movie yeah and it does it
just makes me curious now as to what
they may be or may not be hiding because
most of the Manson shots of him himself
in this trailer come from the roughly
the same scene same with like Bruce Lee
yeah yeah I'm wondering maybe if they're
going to perhaps involve his followers
or the girls more like you brought up
like maybe Brad Pitt's dating somebody
and that kind of brings them close to
the compound in a way personally other
than you know Leo living next mainers I
think I think I'm just most excited for
is the dynamics between DiCaprio and
Brad Pitt okay I'm excited to see Pacino
in this because you know it's important
to do with Jackie Brown and Al Pacino
here yeah like how you've got
essentially got Brad Pitt in DiCaprio
back to do the accents they did in their
previous films but I love their unusual
actor stuntman relationship you know
because I find it interesting when
counters getting interviewed recently
for John wick on Stephen Colbert you
really praised the stunt double and you
rarely hear an actor who does action do
that so it was cool to see that so
having this element here where they seem
unusually close it seems like a lot of
fun just seems like a total blast
alright guys well are you excited for
once a fun at time in Hollywood you
slightly worried about how it's gonna be
handled or do you just have that much
faith in the Tarantino subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell if you like this video please hit
the like button and follow us on patreon